mark hamill has been a household name
for decades and while his names become
synonymous with Star Wars Luke Skywalker
undoubtedly his best-known role there's
a lot more to the actor than the
moisture farmer turned to space wizard
he's so often conflated with one area in
which Mark Hamill and Skywalker are
remarkably similar is in there
definitively unglamorous upbringing
though Hamill didn't grow up as the son
of farmers on a desert planet he was the
fourth of seven children all of whom
were ushered from location to location
as their father was stationed in various
places as a u.s. Navy captain though
Hamill had the exciting opportunity to
live in Japan for part of his youth that
didn't prevent him from starting his
acting career like so many bright-eyed
young people working at a fast food
restaurant and racking up smaller roles
in fact Hamill was even fired from his
job at a jack-in-the-box restaurant for
doing too good an impression of the
chain's mascot character as patrons used
the drive-through window my manager
didn't think it was very funny told me
to go home and never come back for being
in character this of course proved early
on that he had a knack for voicing kooky
clowns a skill that would come in handy
a couple of decades down the line though
Luke Skywalker was his breakout role
Hamill had actually been acting since at
least 1963 when he took on a small role
in the wildly popular soap opera General
Hospital he continued to have brief
on-screen roles and TV hits of the day
including the Bill Cosby Show and The
Partridge Family things went on in this
fashion for some time with Hamill
finally landing a few recurring
characters on the new scooby-doo movies
Jeannie and the Texas wheelers so while
he wasn't on the fast track to stardom
write upon his arrival in Los Angeles he
was certainly putting in the work and
building up a substantial portfolio
something he could present to George
Lucas to seal his fate for the rest of
his life Luke Skywalker was a lucky
break but Hamill was a hard-working kid
proving that destiny isn't the only
factor in achieving stardom in order to
combat the typecasting that would
inevitably result from his portrayal as
the wide-eyed young hero of Destiny Luke
Skywalker Hamill branched out into other
forms of acting
first as many young actors do he spent a
brief stint in the early 80s working in
Broadway plays like the Elephant Man and
Amadeus he followed this endeavor with a
dive headfirst into voice acting as
noted earlier his penchant for
impressions and silly voices would only
aid him further in his career his keen
interest in comic books helped him to
land the role of the Joker in the
beloved cartoon Batman the Animated
Series but Hamill has done work outside
cartoons as well diving into the video
game industry as a voice artist
naturally some of these roles are
reprisals of his work in the Star Wars
and Batman franchises but his first
video game voice opportunity came in
1993 in the mystery thriller Gabriel
Knight sins of the fathers he's
portrayed characters and several sci-fi
military themed games like the Wing
Commander series and one wonders if he
was able to pull from his experience
growing up on naval bases it's no secret
that Hamill is a comic book fan and
thank goodness too considering he
appears at one comic convention after
another to the delight of his adoring
fans
but Hamill has also had a hand in
writing some comics of his own in the
mid-90s right before the Star Wars
prequel films Hamill co-authored the
Black Pearl with his cousin Erik Johnson
the comic featuring art by H M Baker and
published by Dark Horse was a 5 issue
series intended to be collected into one
volume at the end of its run it follows
Luther Drake who inadvertently prevents
an abduction and continues to pursue a
life of nighttime vigilantism sounds a
bit like Batman doesn't it but it's the
post Frank Miller type of Batman dark
and conflicted and morally ambiguous the
comic was originally written as a
screenplay and as recently as 2010
Hamill still had intentions to see this
dark vision brought to life on screen
with himself in the director's chair
while part of Hamill's online presence
is populated by his political thoughts
he's also dedicated a decent chunk of it
to interacting with fans he continues to
have the most delightful knack for
self-deprecating humor and a genuine
gratitude for the fans who have
ported him from the beginning or even
those newer fans who have come to Star
Wars with the newest installments of the
franchise he spends a lot of his
tweeting energy singing the praises of
his fellow actors promoting Star Wars
related news and sharing stories of his
friendships with the likes of the late
adored Carrie Fisher Hamill is a savvy
Twitter user in other words social media
certainly has its problems but with 3.2
million followers it's safe to say the
force is with him when it comes to
interacting with his audience Hamill has
been married to his wife dental
hygienist Mary Lou York since 1978 not
long after the release of a new hope the
couple have three children and one
grandchild and seemed to have
successfully avoided a lot of the
typical drama that Hollywood couples
tend to fall into Hamill and York's long
happy marriage is often attributed to
York's lack of celebrity they broke up
for a period so Hamill could get the
rush of stardom out of his system but in
the end family and stability won out
by marrying a non-celebrity Hamill
wasn't competing with all of Hollywood's
other leading men and he married her not
for her star power or her paparazzi
appeal but because they had a genuine
connection no doubt the two have worked
very hard at keeping their relationship
alive but it is clear that they still
love each other very much and it is
gratifying to see such a healthy
marriage flourish even as Hamill has
returned to the Hollywood limelight with
the final installments of the Star Wars
franchises Skywalker saga despite the
concerns about being typecast Hamill has
done an excellent job of proving he can
have a satisfying and successful career
outside Star Wars so as the torch has
passed from Luke to Rey we see Hamill
continuing in much the same manner as
usual he dons the animated white face of
the Joker time and again in various new
animated DC series and makes guest
appearances on TV series like the Big
Bang Theory
I'm gonna meet him here but some roles
and projects stand out more than others
he put his villainous voice to good use
as the devious doll Chucky in the 2019
film child's play before taking the role
of the scientist in the Dark Crystal age
of resistance the long hyped prequel to
Jim Henson's 1982 cult classic puppet
fueled Fantasia continuing as long
appreciation for the comics medium he's
also taken a role in Amazon's adaptation
of Robert Kirkman Corey Walker and Ryan
at Lee's invincible which chronicles the
life of the son of a superhero still in
the spotlight after all these years Mark
Hamill has proven he has the talent to
tackle a wide variety of roles and we
can't wait to see what he does next
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]